this morning hundreds are still homeless  after a huge fire downtown sunday  morning at least 10 buildings two dozen  cars were destroyed some of those  evacuated have been able to return home  but one family discovered in the time  they were out of the house most things  inside were stolen  josh had been taken out of the office  doors in my office they had gone through  his documents  they took a number of medications  all kinds of things and i'm still  discovering what's missing  that's just so frustrating the family is  now working with neighbors on some  security there in what's left of the  property red cross staff are also  helping those who've been impacted by  the fire if you'd like to help we have  details at eightnewsnow.com